6 versus 1 cita con mujeres basado en
sus tipos de cuerpo
[Música]
me llamo maca y tengo 23 años soy de los
ángeles california y creo contenido para
las redes sociales ronda 1 pies
[Música]
interesantes
son pies muy interesantes debo decir que
algunas de ustedes tienen una muy linda
pedicura aquí pero hay otras chicas que
mis pies se ven mucho mejor
chicos cuál es su tipo de cuerpo ideal
alguien que esté en forma no tiene que
ser muy fuerte o musculoso pero sí debe
tener gran confianza en sí mismo la
personalidad es lo que define si un
chico me gusta o no también que les
guste el aire libre y ser activos porque
si no disfrutan eso es muy difícil que
quiera relacionarme con ello cuerpo alto
en forma
pero no demasiado robusto porque soy una
persona pequeña prefiero a alguien que
no pueda aplastar la parte si no tienes
que ser adicto al gimnasio ni parecerte
a chris evans aunque él es muy guapo y
tiene un trasero hermoso y eso me como
pero no tienes que parecerte a él para
gusto prefiero a alguien que sea más
alto que yo aunque podrías para alguien
5 cm menos que yo es mi tope y no es
negociable
yo diría que alguien que esté en forma y
se cuide alguien con fuerza para
cargarme si
he salido con gente de todas las
estaturas y tipos de cuerpo así que yo
no discrimino cariño es que no pude
evitar mirar el tatuaje que dice
bittersweet agridulce en inglés me gusta
mucho
ellas son amantes de los tatuajes
y tengo tres bien genial necesitas
muchos más para superarme
creo que todos
lo tengo dos por eso queremos hacernos
un tatuaje
ronda 1 eliminación
[Música]
mi decisión no se basa en el aspecto de
los pies me encantan las respuestas de
esta chica
pero tendré que eliminar a la número uno
con
[Música]
y
si es así lo siento pero eran los únicos
que no estaban muy cuidados por eso me
gusta mucho ir de excursión entonces el
esmalte de uñas se arruina y también me
gusta ir de excursión
que hice
[Risas]
ronda dos piernas
[Música]
algunas más reveladoras que otras pero
ve un short sí bien porque eso es un
short trampa
mis padres van a ver esto y
es un poco conservador quizás para mí es
conservador bien bien comprendo bien
número 5 bueno muchos tatuajes por ahí
son pequeños dibujos de perritos al azar
por todo el cuerpo
soy stripper así que estoy en ropa
interior para ganarme la vida diría que
esto también es mi idioma normal y
stripper qué es lo que te gusta de tu
trabajo el dinero solo el dinero y quise
usar algo un poco más conservador no lo
hago siempre creo que hay que dejar un
poco a la imaginación
soy en claro bien antes una de ustedes
dijo algo sé apreciar cargada
una pregunta especial para ti es lo que
yo diría no
sólo diré que prefiero a alguien que se
preocupe por complacer a la otra persona
más que a sí mismo bien que tan agusto
se sienten con su cuerpo mientras crecía
no me gustaba pero al hacerme mayor todo
comenzó a cambiar la verdad me siento
muy segura de mí misma como puedes ver
si yo me siento muy segura y agusto con
mi cuerpo pero fue un proceso no fue
algo que sucediera naturalmente siempre
he sido la chica más grande y más alta y
además yo soy bea' racial y crecí con
una madre blanca me llevó mucho tiempo
sentirme cómoda conmigo misma en la
escuela recuerdo que todos solían
burlarse de mí por ser muy delgada
intento aprender a amar mi cuerpo a
cualquier edad y sentirme cómoda con él
sin importar cómo se vea ahora me siento
muy bien todo el tiempo que bien todos
tenemos inseguridades hechos también las
tengo pero voy al gimnasio un par de
veces a la semana y he entrenado con
pesas durante casi un año siento que eso
me ha ayudado a ganar confianza y a
sentirme cómoda con mi cuerpo hay mucha
presión en la industria para hacerse
cirugía plástica y yo estoy a favor de
la cirugía plástica pero es difícil
estar en una industria donde muchas
personas recurren a ella y no preguntar
te la necesito debería hacerme la pero
yo diría que me siento bastante a gusto
con mis gustos me gustan las mujeres
porque tan a gusto te sientes con tu
cuerpo y siento muy a gusto con mi
cuerpo
ronda 2 eliminación cuentas de bolt y
minar y 2 rompe la próxima es la
bien
no sé qué hacer
voy a eliminar a la número
3 bien
adiós nenas
gracias es muy divertido gusto conocerte
también es un placer gusto justo porque
gracias rayos me agradó conocerte adiós
adiós maldición esto es muy difícil para
mí
número 2
sí
y
esto es sólo un juego
ronda 3 gusto
bien ahora díganme qué es lo que menos
les gusta de su cuerpo a mis pechos o mi
nariz creo que nunca me haría una
cirugía aunque me siento un poco
insegura por mis pechos no quiero ser de
las que dicen si haré lo que me digas
siempre haré lo contrario qué significa
esa llave
de mi corazón
estoy segura de mí y me gusta el cuerpo
que tengo pero al mismo tiempo si siento
inseguridad o si experimento dismorfia
corporal o algo así debido a mi cuerpo
no se acepta que tenga inseguridades o
que las expresen porque alguien podría
tener un tipo de cuerpo diferente que
está más señalado de mala manera por la
sociedad al ser una chica con curvas es
normal ser más robusta y con piernas más
gruesas que muchos modelos de redes
sociales en general pero siempre tenemos
un buen ángulo que nos ayuda a ocultar
lo que no queremos mostrar tanto porque
están solteras y que buscan en una
pareja
soltera quizás por mi mal gusto para los
chicos solo he estado en una relación
técnicamente y ni siquiera la
etiquetamos porque era muy tóxica y
emocionalmente abusiva yo tenía que en
este momento estoy soltera porque soy
una persona muy exigente estoy abierta a
salir y tener citas casuales y
divertirme un poco no estoy buscando la
persona indicada ni nada de eso
en realidad me mudé aquí desde la costa
este por mi ex de ese momento creo que
me puse mi mejor traje de tonta al venir
acá la verdad no funcionó no funcionó
estoy buscando alguien que sea honesto
ronda 3 eliminación
[Música]
bien la persona que voy a eliminar esta
vez por desgracia es la número
hola hola
hola
me gusta tu arte es una historia de vida
gracias tiene tiene los ojos muy lindos
chicas es muy guapo gracias por eso
me gustan los corazones gracias
voy a tener que eliminar a la número
adiós
es un placer gracias a rayos
no lo siento es que parecía es muy muy
tímida tico me gustaron sus respuestas
primero las mismas gafas que tú en serio
cuál es tu afección no bajo
hipermetropía y nieve o cuando ves mal
mal de lejos
[Risas]
más alto que él
no es nada está bien fue un placer
conocerte entiendas
puede salir
[Música]
puedo abrazar
y tienes unos lindos tatuajes y también
me gustaron tus respuestas sobre todo la
de la llave de tu corazón
estoy muy emocionado por ver qué pasa
esta es una situación sueño y moda
no sé dónde mirar no sé dónde do tu
número redes sociales